well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at
oh excuse me it's not a good start is it
that's what is on the front pages
uh in the next half hour then we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
political editor of the liverpool echo
liam thorpe
and soon to be joined by fingers crossed
the telegraph's assistant comment editor
olivia artley well good to have you on
anyway speak to you in just a moment
let's uh
take a look at the front pages shall we
uh the telegraph reports that british
taxpayers
had a hand in funding the work of a
vaccine factory in the netherlands which
is the subject of a blockade by the
european commission
the daily mail hears that trials of
vaccine passports
could begin as soon as next month
the daily mirror reporting on a 400
million pound fund
for the arts and entertainment industry
to bounce back from lockdown
telling its readers to get set for a
summer of fun
the sun reporting that while travel to
the continent may not be possible this
summer
holidaymakers may instead be tempted by
bahrain
where the vaccine rollout has been
relatively swift
looking ahead to the announcement due on
monday
by the prime minister the guardian leads
with
baroness doreen lawrence whose son
stephen was murdered
in a racially motivated attack in the
1990s insisting
the findings of a landmark government
report on race relations provide
a green light for racists the eye has an
investigation into private sector jobs
taken by more than
60 members of david cameron's government
in the two years after they left which
are understood to have been
directly relevant to their previous
ministerial positions
yorkshire post reports on the
significant disparity
in the number of government contracts
awarded to firms in the north
compared to their counterparts in london
and the south
east and the star gives its readers a
quiz
on emojis
i've got time to read all of that i'll
have a look in a minute uh liam thorpe
is here
still no olivia at me you're on your own
i'm afraid um luckily there's plenty to
talk about is there not
so daily mail suggesting that covid
passport
trials to begin this they say is an
exclusive tell us more
yes so it's something that's obviously
been discussed
for a while and and has sort of been
hinted at there's
there's obviously a lot of debate on
either side about about whether this is
the right way to go but it seems now
that the government is moving
more more and more towards the idea of
of covered passports or
some kind of certification i think
what's important to say about this is
that
it's not necessarily you must you can
only go into certain events if you have
had the vaccine that it looks like
there's going to be a kind of
three-pronged approach whether it's
potentially people who've had a test
you've had a negative test who've had
a jab or who have antibodies um so it's
obviously just a way of trying to ensure
that everyone is going to these major
events
is free of covered and i personally
think that's quite a good thing um so
they're going to be trialing it we've
heard a bit about this already they're
going to be trialing it at the fa cup
final
at things like the world snooker
championships we've actually been told
in liverpool where i am that
there's good that the city's going to
form part of the trial as well in terms
of some smaller scale events like a
uh night nightclub nights and things
like that and obviously this is all
about
building up to you know what we're all
hoping for which is
some sort of normality when it comes to
june the 21st or
or around that time so it's all about
getting your ducks in a row
so that hopefully um things can be a
little bit back to normal in the summer
yes um interestingly the the mail says
their introduction is certain to trigger
a huge political row
um last night 72 mps including
libertarian tories
and senior labor figures issued a joint
statement branding vaccine passports
divisive and discriminatory and vowing
to oppose them
but as you said it's about changing
behavior you go to somewhere
and you have confidence what's your
reading um
of how people might what their attitude
to this might be do you think people
would be largely supportive
i think i think when you've seen some of
the polling that people are
largely supportive i think it was the
same when when it came to the lockdown
generally people are they're up for
doing what's necessary
to get us out of this mess and get some
kind of normality
obviously the tories will be concerned
you know there is a growing backbench
revolt and as you mentioned
some of the more libertarian mps you
know this is this is obviously
really not what they believe in they
believe in in the freedom to do what you
want but
you know i mean when you go to certain
countries now because of other diseases
you do have to have you know uh
vaccinations you have to show
records that you've um that you're clear
of certain diseases you know this isn't
a totally new thing
and we are still in in this pandemic you
know we're not out of it
we are doing really well with the
vaccines we're getting to a place where
where things are starting to look a bit
more normal this
i have to say i've been deeply critical
of the government's approach in terms of
containing the pandemic in the past
i'm actually pleased to see them taking
some serious precautions when it comes
to
make keeping control of the virus as we
kind of build back to normality
yes telegraph too with this um
suggesting that these pilots are going
to start within weeks
which is interesting isn't it uh people
going to the events will be asked to
take a covid19 test
to gain entry another after attendance
uh to stop any spreading of the virus or
so any spreading can be
monitored i mean with all of this and
obviously we've got the easter weekend
haven't we and everyone's very aware of
how many people will be out perhaps the
cold weather will tempt people indoors
or
tempt them not to meet who knows and we
have to remember that we're dealing with
the kent variant here at which
france is beginning to see only too well
it spreads easily it
has high transmissibility
exactly and you know we saw um president
macron yesterday ordering another
lockdown in france obviously they are in
a different situation and they're taking
different decisions but you know we i've
been following
covid rates certainly locally here for
the past year and we only have to look
at what happened in december
previously in september to see just how
quickly these things
can escalate you know we were in here in
liverpool
you know you'll remember that we went
into tier two in december and our rates
were around sort of
70 60 cases per 100 000 by
early january it was over a thousand so
these things really can escalate
especially as you say
with vet new variants that spread more
rapidly what we're obviously hoping for
this time
is when when we do inevitably see
numbers go up a little bit which i think
we're all expecting
is that obviously enough people
hopefully in the vulnerable categories
have been vaccinated
so that we won't see those same levels
of hospitalization and deaths
but we need to keep control of it that's
just a that's just a fact um we've heard
chris whitty talking about how we will
be able to live amongst it but we're not
quite
at that level yet because everyone
hasn't been vaccinated so until that
happens i think it's a trade-off really
if we want to to continue on the road
back to normality
before everybody then we have to have
some kind of
way of keeping that in check and and you
know i i personally
would be more than happy to to abide by
rules if it meant that i could go and
watch the football for example
oh everyone's got a thing haven't they
absolutely um
and chris whitty uh makes the front page
of the daily express day we hope no more
lockdowns
talking about treating it like flu but
as you say we're not not there yet and
one member of sage i heard on today said
by this time next year hopefully it will
kind of gone away
but as you say we're still not there yet
and we heard the message from
matt hancock this week don't blow it now
that's the i mean that's the great
appeal to people isn't it
it is and look it's it's it's really
understandable that people are tired you
know
you know we've seen some difficult
scenes of kind of young people gathering
much bigger numbers and
you know i do i do really feel for some
you know young people
who have been to university and had a
really torrid time and suddenly they've
got this kind of taste of freedom
and that they you know they want to go
and enjoy it and we've seen that in
in parks and and and open spaces the
problem is
if you move too quickly in that
direction and we could all find
ourselves back in
in that difficult situation i think what
chris whittie to be fair to him has been
pretty consistent on this i remember him
saying
months ago even though it seemed like it
wasn't really possible that that we
would get to a stage where there would
have to be that decision
taken where enough people have been
vaccinated and we've
we've brought rates down where you know
we maybe don't get to a point where we
eradicate code but we have to sort of
learn to live amongst it i don't think
clearly that we're there yet and we need
the rollout to get to everyone it's
obviously going very well
but yeah i think you know there's a bit
of a building consensus that we will
probably have to find a way to live
amongst
this virus we just have to manage it as
well as we can with with vaccines and
with booster jobs as well in the winter
obviously the winter will be the big
massive test because there are some
suggestions that
we may need extra measures when it comes
to the winter in terms of the usual
winter pressures that we face
yeah um olivia utley uh joins us now uh
telegraph's assistant comment editor
just in time too because i'm about to
get to the sun which for
reasons of being in liverpool liam will
not talk about
the planes to spain now mainly to
bahrain
euro holes blow but golf is okay this is
an exclusive by
political editor harry cole uh also of
this parish
uh suggesting he's been given or tipped
the wink that
he knows what's going to happen next
week with the great reveal on holidays
which
many people want to know what does it
say then olivia
yeah so it's that europe will probably
be off
limits um which is huge really um
considering you know europe's our
closest allies this is
really gonna mess with um the
the our future relationship with the eu
after
brexit um and so the eu's probably gonna
be off-limits um
and that's obviously huge for most
people who have family abroad have
family
in the eu um and it's gonna be
it's gonna be difficult for people to to
hear that but it sounds like we might be
able to get some holidays
um just just to perhaps bahrain um
which will be a bit different for
everyone next year yes indeed so
so um the online copy suggests that
summer holiday hot spots will be ranked
under a new traffic light system letting
brits fly to so-called green
countries which have both low covered
rates and strong vaccine roll
outs at them at the moment that would
leave bahrain dubai and the u.s
top destination wish lists nations with
high virus cases and slow job rollouts
will require more quarantining so for
example you get green
amber and red red rivals must isolate on
their return
in an authorized hotel at their own cost
as they do currently
amber would be light green but those
entering the uk must isolate at home for
10 days after arrival
and then the green is anyone returning
from these countries must take a
pre-flight lateral flow test
at their own cost then take a sequencing
test within days
of landing to check for new strains june
this article says will be the earliest
boris johnson suggests that borders
can open boris johnson publishing the
findings of the global travel task force
on monday now most people i suppose go
to europe
liam uh we heard the world health
organization today
uh the or the the europe uh envoy of it
suggests that um europe's vaccine
rollout has simply not been good enough
i think that's pretty clear um all round
really you know
it's it's one of the it's one of those
funny situations where i have been
critical of the government in terms of
its handling of the pandemic but you
can't really argue with
the fact that our vaccine rollout is
going well and that's what goes into a
position where
we may be able to start to to look at
opening things up
it's clear that in the eu things just
haven't gone well it's been badly
managed
it there now seems to be an element of
desperation when it comes to talk of
of blockades and diverting things and
and those kind of
you know slightly the rhetoric stepped
up into a slightly desperate tone now
i understand that in a way because
obviously they're under massive pressure
but that's possibly because of their own
mistakes that they've made it does feel
like on this particular issue
the uk acted pretty quickly and has
managed to get that vaccine
rolled out i must admit i i'm surprised
at how well it's gone but you know
you can't really argue with the figures
yeah um the sun continuing that
most of europe is poised for amber
status uh the u.s gulf states israel
could be classed as green uh malta is
obviously doing too
well too we speculate uh beyond that i
suppose
and they'll be really disappointing for
many people who are hoping to get away
after basically being penned in their
homes for months and months olivia
but the daily mirror sells us of um get
set for a summer of fun
400 million pounds fund for attractions
and events to
to prepare for for the holiday season
tell us more about that
yeah so um this is the good side
um we're gonna get this summer fun which
we've all been talking about which is
essentially going to involve
money being pumped into the kind of fun
industries into uh the arts um and into
theater
uh sports gonna obviously be huge this
summer so there's gonna be a lot of
a push to have a big summer in the uk
spending money which you know lots of
people have been saving up money
uh those who have been fortunate enough
their jobs have been able to go out have
been have been storing money up and are
going to be encouraged to
to spend it in a big sort of blowout in
a big uk summer
so that i think is going to be the
messaging from the government over there
over the next few months there are a few
countries which you might be able to
uh travel to without too much difficulty
but on the whole it'll be travel around
the uk
um we'll put some money into allowing
there to be
a sort of festival atmosphere in the uk
and you spend your money here and
that'll get the economy going again
well we are way more news on travel and
indeed on the announcement about the 400
million for arts and entertainment um
or lots of lots of covered news still to
come no doubt
as we head to the easter weekend well
coming up though baroness dorian
lawrence reacts angrily to the
government's report on race relations
we will look at that in more detail in
just a moment
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now liam thorpe
and olivia artley welcome back to both
of you
liam should we go to the guardian now
which looks again
at this number 10 commissioned report on
disparities in
in race and so on and speaks to the
mother of uh the murdered student
stephen lawrence who has a lot to say on
this
yeah so this is kind of the the second
day really of fallout of
of the the kind of reaction to this um
report which
it seems to be kind of growing um the
the you know the the frustrations and
the criticism of it
this is perhaps one of the one of the
most important and strongest
interventions from dorian lawrence who
of course is
the mother of stephen lawrence who has
been campaigning um against racism
and following the murder of her son for
18 years and she said that the
the findings of the report the way it
was put together some of the tone of it
um you know is potentially going to put
back the fight against
racism and discrimination by 20 years
and said that it's potentially giving
racists the green light which is you
know really striking criticism from such
a
respected person and you know an
influential campaigner
i think we've also seen today that some
of the academics who are sort of
referenced in the report
have basically said that they weren't
consulted uh that they
that their their their words or their
research was used but they weren't
told that it was going to be in this
report so we are
seeing more and more criticism of this
report and we've seen
uh people from these communities talk
about it being patronizing
talk about it as i say pushing that um
the fight back and and even some of the
passages particularly some of the stuff
about slavery is really controversial
and so yeah it's it's another day and
more fallout from from this government
report and difficult questions for the
government who of course obviously
also lost a key advisor in this area um
just today or yesterday was it so i
think the dorian lawrence intervention
takes this up a notch
and it will it will cause real concern
for the government yeah i think it was
today it's difficult because we deal
with tomorrow's news in the papers and
we can't remember
what day it is do we i always get caught
out and let's go to the daily telegraph
now olivia
um google urges its staff to return to
the office and i go goodness me no the
messages still work from home
but they mean after the pandemic and
everyone's wondered what big companies
will do
about how life will change don't they
and especially these tech
based companies yeah i find it's really
fascinating it seems to have been over
the last sort of three or four months
quite a lot of these
big tech companies have decided that the
work from
home shift can't be permanent because a
few months ago we were sort of hearing
that you know this was the future of
of life and no one was going to go back
to the office as was and et cetera et
cetera
and just now the changes are happening
and you sort of wonder whether that's
whether that's this kind of realization
once once you're getting more and more
people starting
um in a job and realizing that's
actually very difficult to learn when
you're learning from home
um and you know i found that starting a
new job in lockdown um i just
i'm allowed to go into the office as a
journalist and so i have been going in
as much as i possibly can and i realize
that
i learn a lot more sitting next my boss
has been doing the job for
for 10 years um and i think more people
will be finding that companies will be
realizing that their new talent actually
isn't really developing in their roles
so i think there are there's some of
these problems which
which are only recognizable in the long
term and it's sort of been fudged for
the last year but as we move into the
second year
becomes a lot more difficult so i think
we'll be seeing more and more of this
and liam just very quickly very
important for younger people
uh they're finding uh whose job work
home life it becomes their bedroom
especially
if they're in shared accommodation you
you know that's it then isn't it
absolutely you know i'm fortunate enough
to to have a room in my
house um which i didn't have by the way
i actually moved into this house mid
pandemic so i kind of i've got the
um the evidence really of working in in
a tiny sort of
flat and then and then obviously being
fortunate enough to have a room
where i use my office you know i found
it really really difficult when
trying to separate work and life um and
obviously
you know the young people living in
really small house shares with six other
people
at their desk with their bed behind them
it's not conducive really
i'm gonna i'm well i've got to get to
the weather it's easter weekend you know
we're allowed out actually uh we'll see
a half 11 thank you
don't forget as well if you've missed it
tonight it will be available shortly and
every night on our youtube channel
the it there being the press preview to
the weather now